does the prime minister find it
acceptable that his home secretary has
overseen one of the slowest most
bureaucratic and incompetent refugee
responses in the whole of europe
mr speaker i think everybody sympathizes
with the plight of of refugees and and
uh this government wants to do
everything we can to to welcome them and
and that is indeed what we are doing and
the numbers are uh almost a thousand as
i speak to uh to him today and they will
rise very sharply mr speaker uh
they are uncapped we expect those
numbers to rise uh to uh in the region
of the hundreds of thousands uh as as
the uh as vladimir putin doubles down in
his attacks we will go further mr
speaker and there will be uh routes by
which the whole country can offer uh uh
offer a welcome uh to people from uh
ukraine vulnerable people fleeing uh
from ukraine and my right honourable
friend the secretary of state uh for uh
for leveling up we'll be setting out
that route in the course of the next few
days this government has a proud proud
record we've done more to resettle
vulnerable people than any other
european country since 2015.
you're black folks
i don't think the prime minister
understands the scale of the challenge
or the other urgency these are people
fleeing war crimes torn apart from their
families as their homes are failed and
the home secretary is blocking them with
endless paperwork this isn't just
incompetence this is ideology in the
face of the biggest refugee crisis in
europe since the second world war the uk
government won't set aside the hostile
environment by the way we're seeing the
hostile environment this afternoon they
might quite down a bit
we've seen this too many times from a
tory home office the windrush scandal
the go home vans the inhumane
nationality and borders bill the uk home
office is raising barriers and
bureaucracy when we should be offering
care and compassion prime minister do
not let the history of failure repeat
itself scotland stands ready to offer
sanctuary and refuge so will the prime
minister
join with the rest of the european
continent and waive the visa
restrictions for refugees fleeing war in
ukraine
mr speaker this country has an
unparalleled record and look just just
since i have been prime minister look at
what the numbers we've taken from
afghanistan uh from hong kong mr speaker
he lectures the home secretary this is
the government unlike any other the
prime minister the deputy prime minister
the home secretary are directly
descended mr speaker from refugees and
we understand we understand how much
refugees have to give to this country
and we understand how much this country
has to gain from welcoming refugees and
we will be generous and we are being
generous mr speaker and what we are
doing is making sure that in those in
those neighboring countries the uk is
out in front giving the humanitarian
assistance
and we are in every capital mr speaker
they laugh mr speaker they mock they
scoff this country and is leading in
every respect but we are also the single
biggest donor of humanitarian aid
to the ukraine war zone mr speaker the
single biggest owner he should be proud
of that